clacton-on-sea the largest town on the
Essex sunshine coast in the 50s this
pleasure pier was teeming with tourists
now it's buffeted by tough economic
headwinds according to Sky data Clapton
is the most Euroskeptic constituency
half of residents are aged over 55
sixty-three percent aren't in full-time
employment and seventy one percent earn
less than 20,000 pounds a year all of
these groups are more likely to vote out
so why are the people who live here and
who elected you Kip's only MP so keen to
leave the EU we're just hearing klaxon
today because we've done some research
that shows its most Euroskeptic place in
the United Kingdom right does that
surprise you know it's over all very
well for these good doers to say well
you gotta let I mean I couldn't care
less if you was green yellow or black
but if you're coming into this country
coming with a job you interested in the
EU referendum oh yeah oh yeah I don't
want to come out oh definitely for a
place ready to turn its back on the EU
clacton has some very European ties in
its heyday when it was swimming with
day-trippers the district of tendering
twinned with towns in France Germany and
Poland speak to people in collective and
they'll tell you they're worried about
immigration security and other European
countries getting a better deal twinning
with towns 30 years ago mo felt like
they were creating a big happy new
family now although it's a relationship
that most people here want to end
vinnitsa in Poland is Clapton's most
recent twinning according to Sky data
fifty-three percent of people think EU
immigration undermines British culture
and values just twenty eight percent
disagree so how do people in this
historic city feel about Clapton's
attitudes to Eastern European
immigration I've heard that it's not
that good that they're not very kind
suppose the English people I mean I
don't have anything to them but it's the
same situation advertisers who have now
in Poland with people from Ukraine they
are getting their worst wages those jobs
people that were coming from Eastern
Europe they are taking the jobs position
from the UK people that are obviously
very well i would say educated fold of
closed borders with french towns like
pictures balance are a european benefit
that for some is now more of a risk sky
data shows that 22% think the UK would
be safer outside the EU with just
sixteen percent feeling safer inside but
that means most people haven't been
persuaded either way voters are worried
about terror and security but neither
campaign has managed to ease their fears
Barack is in prosperous Germany the
heart of the european project 51-percent
of Britain's think the UK gets a raw
deal compared to their EU counterparts
that sense of unfairness is particularly
strong among the old the less well-off
and supporters of you Kip for voters in
clacton the towns they are twinned with
reflect their deepest concerns with less
than 10 weeks of campaigning to go
residents here may be hard to convince
but across the country many are still
undecided so if you read Sky News
clapton